ils sont plus de 780 milles cette année
à passer une journée dans un centre du
service national
c'est la dernière étape obligatoire pour
tous ces jeunes de 17 à 25 ans au
programme présentation des métiers de la
défense du recrutement mais aussi
sensibilisation à la sécurité routière
une journée de dialogue avec des
animateurs sur des sujets d'actualité et
les menaces qui pèsent sur la france
depuis les récents attentats les jeunes
se sentent très concernés par le travail
des armées qu'en voile et les
patrouilles dans la gare on voit les
militaires des filets et aujourd'hui on
se dit vraiment c'est quelque chose
d'important qui font au cours de la
journée ils échangent avec des
militaires sur leur métier leur parcours
leur vie mais le centre qui voit passer
près de 150 jeunes par jour a aussi pour
mission de détecter les jeunes en
difficulté de lecture ou en échec
scolaire pour l'armée c'est un enjeu de
cohésion sociale sensibiliser tous les
jeunes à l'importance de la défense a
expliqué ses missions et ses moyens et
pourquoi pas établir des contacts en vue
d'un recrutement et nous explique qu'il
ya beaucoup de métier dans l'armée que
c'est pas parce que par exemple je suis
en commerce que je pourrais pas faire
mécanicien ou que je pourrais pas faire
infirmière ou quelque chose comme ça il
y en a énormément j'ai appris beaucoup
de choses l'armée de terre l'armée de
l'air et la marine recrute
en effet chaque année 21 mille jeunes
pour des postes très variés des jeunes
sans diplôme
jusqu'à des bac + 5 ondes et sur la
recherche de valeurs prônées sur la
recherche structure on est sur la
recherche de solidarité et puis oui bien
entendu il reste dieu soit loué en cours
le moule aventures de poids à partir à
l'étranger
certains aussi viennent chez nous avec
l'espoir d'avoir l'espoir justifier
d'avoir une formation qualifiante
ce qui est vraiment le cas en fin de
journée pour tous ces jeunes avec un
questionnaire et la remise de leur
certificat individuel de participation
sésame qui fait d'eux désormais un
citoyen ou une citoyenne